[Music]
on this thursday night critical care in
a deepening crisis
canada's hospitals are running out of
staff they're exhausted and they're
suffering from ptsd and rooms for
patients
canada's mission to help train ukrainian
civilians to battle russian forces we
have now entered a new and very
dangerous phase of this conflict as we
meet the doctors saving lives in this
bombed out ukrainian hospital
the russian prison punishment for
american basketball star brittany griner
made an honest mistake and her fight for
freedom plus sos at sea
the man trapped under a boat waiting 16
hours to be rescued
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us the situation at hospitals across the
country appears to be getting worse by
the day today the president of canada's
largest nurses union called on the prime
minister and the provincial governments
to address the staffing shortage in our
overburdened health care system
canadians across the country are feeling
the negative impacts of government in
action and this piecemealing
piecemealing that they're trying to do
to give care all levels of government
have a responsibility to ensure that
canadians have access to high quality
public health care
now the problems plaguing our health
care system were predicted and diagnosed
years ago but as sean o'shea explains in
our top story tonight the prognosis
remains unclear
in downtown toronto it isn't business as
usual at one of the city's most
important health care centers
toronto general hospital operating under
a critical care bed alert meaning there
isn't room here for the most serious
cases right now be mindful we don't have
the staffing or capacity to accept them
at this point in time staff shortages in
hospitals around the country are a
growing problem with no simple solution
healthcare workers who are feeling
overworked burnt out under resourced
and we have to do something about it
there aren't enough nurses aren't enough
support staff and every week it's only
getting worse they were not built to see
the amount of pain suffering and deaths
that they have seen ontario's nurses
union says that province alone needs 30
thousand more nurses can we do better we
can always strive to do better can we
can the hospitals do better 100 percent
they can do better but hospitals say
they can't find enough qualified nurses
quickly enough or help foreign trade
nurses meet canadian standards so health
networks are rethinking how they use
what little remaining staff they have
how do we take people with narrower
scopes or narrower skill sets and and
use them to really support our nursing
and physician colleagues in particular
the health care crunch doesn't just
affect those needing urgent care now in
many places trying to find a family
doctor is more difficult than ever we've
been on the waiting list for
close to a year and it's been really
hard for us to find one this family with
a two-year-old and a newborn he'll need
a regular medical procedure just got a
doctor if it was easier to get a family
doctor that would be great we're
throwing everything we possibly can i'm
doing a lot of listening a lot of
learning finding out where the
challenges are where the opportunities
are the most serious challenges are in
emergency departments and intensive care
units wait times have ballooned to 20
hours many have had to close their
emergency departments and icu beds and
life-saving surgeries and treatments
like chemotherapy continue to be put on
hold adding even more backlog to the
system and its front-line workers and
the patients who can't afford to wait
sean o'shea global news toronto
in bc's southern interior another batch
of homes have been placed under
evacuation order it's due to the
still-growing caramias creek wildfire
helicopters are dumping water on the
fire and ground crews are working around
the clock to protect homes in the
southern okanagan fire officials say the
karemius creek blaze has nearly doubled
in size since it was last mapped but
much of that growth is due to controlled
burns designated to stop its spread
despite the arrival of cooler weather
there are more than 60 active wildfires
burning around the province and british
columbians are being told to expect the
extreme fire danger to persist for at
least several more weeks
an investigation is underway in montreal
tonight after police shot and killed a
man suspected in three homicides the
shooting happened this morning outside a
motel investigators believe the suspect
was involved in three seemingly random
shootings in montreal and laval over the
past 48 hours two men were killed in
separate shootings on tuesday night and
a third man was shot and killed in laval
last night police think the 26-year-old
suspect acted alone
such events cannot be tolerated
indeed montrealers should feel safe to
walk in each neighborhood at whole time
in all places
quebec's provincial police will take
over the investigation into the three
fatal shootings while the province's
police watchdog is looking into the
suspect's death
a retired supreme court judge will lead
an independent review into hockey canada
thomas cromwell is going to investigate
hockey canada's use of its national
equity fund to settle sexual claims as
well as the organization's governance
structure and systems the review was
announced last month after news broke
members of the 2018 world junior team
were accused of a group sexual assault
and hockey canada reached a settlement
with the complainant
canada is sending members of the
military to the united kingdom to help
train ukrainians to fight for four
months they'll teach civilians how to
use weapons how to administer first aid
and military law and as mercedes
stevenson reports it's not the only new
mission canada is involved with
as canada officially and publicly
announces it is getting back into the
business of training ukrainians to fight
there is a much more secretive mission
canada is involved in on the ground
multiple sources say elite canadian
operators from the canadian special
operations command are working in the
shadows to help train ukrainian troops
and facilitate weapons and equipment
delivery the minister of national
defense did not deny the reports but was
tight-lipped it would be imprudent for
me to provide that information today the
minister announced 225 canadian military
personnel will deploy to the united
kingdom working with the british army to
turn ukrainian civilians who have signed
up to fight russia into soldiers
it is the relaunch of operation unifier
the mission to train ukrainian troops
originally in ukraine that was suspended
just before russia attacked we are
fulfilling our promise to resume large
scale training under operation unifier
canadian troops will start training
their ukrainian recruits with the basics
everything from frontline fighting
skills to patrolling weapons handling
and first aid
imparting basic skills and generating
new recruits is critical because of the
type of war ukraine finds itself in the
ukrainians are in a war of attrition
with the russians
and they are sustaining very high
casualties training troops is something
canada is particularly skilled at these
are something that canada has particular
expertise in both within nato and sort
of around western allied countries
the past training from operation unifier
and similar allied programs have proven
worth their weight in gold in terms of
the skills and professionalism imparted
to ukrainian soldiers which took the
russian military by surprise
the first contingent of canadian troops
will come from 3rd battalion of princess
patricia's canadian light infantry based
in edmonton and will deploy next week
canadians have also been training
ukrainians already on how to use those
m7777 howitzer guns that canada has sent
over pharah mercedes-stevenson in ottawa
thank you mercedes
opposition mps grilled ministers at a
parliamentary committee who defended
their decision to relax russian
sanctions and export gas turbine parts
repaired in montreal last month the
government defended that as necessary to
get gas to europeans but russia's gas
prompt continues to stall and reduce gas
flow blaming a lack of documents from
western nations and the canadian
government now says the decision was all
about calling putin's bluff
at the time you made this decision uh
was there any discussion of calling mr
food's bluff
at the time of the incident absolutely
and and and certainly i discussed that
with minister
german energy minister we urge you do
not take the bait
there was no need to wait the sanctions
to call putin's regime bluff
and simply liar
ukrainian german and european union
ambassadors to canada testified as well
as the ukrainian canadian congress which
urged the government to revoke the
permits
what had been a sprawling medical
complex in peacetime ukraine has now
been reduced to a single damaged
building near the front line due to
danger from snipers the few doctors
still on duty have to avoid the
operating room and the generator that
they rely on for power is so loud that
they often can't tell how close the
bombs are falling our europe bureau
chief crystal gomezing was granted
special access to see firsthand how
medical teams there are enduring
the morgue a dental facility a
sterilization building and therapeutics
clinic
all gone neurologist ilona boutiva says
of the 27 doctors who worked here before
the war
five remain
there were such cases when civilians
were brought in with great damage there
was heavy shelling and we provided help
in the corridor her reality is so
different from her dreams
this neurologist scrolling through her
phone to show me the application she
started a few years back to move to
canada to practice medicine
hospital staff have requested we not
name the town it's located in
[Music]
both soldiers and civilians are treated
here the hospital is dark the hallway's
small and there's little equipment to be
seen this is the hospital's bomb shelter
and it's only really used by the doctors
when it's absolutely necessary when the
shelling is very very close and very
loud it's not the most comfortable place
for doctors or patients but they've
actually operated on someone down here
shrapnel was pulled from a patient while
in the bunker cell phone video was taken
of the operation
phones were also used to provide the
doctors with some light to work
above ground on the top floor
it's the opposite problem
this room doesn't get used the windows
and all the natural light she explains
make the staff vulnerable to sniper fire
the injuries seen here are critical and
the volume of patients can be
overwhelming 10 wounded soldiers can
arrive at once all in dire need of
urgent care medical personnel from keeve
are now helping on site
our hospitals are not very well equipped
we bring a lot with us and volunteers
help us
around town you don't see many children
or open businesses just fortified
bunkers open fields and destruction the
hospital complex has been shelled at
least five times since february 24th
i have two daughters five and ten and
when it was dangerous here i put them on
an evacuation bus
separated from family and overworked the
war has been unrelenting for these
doctors who say everything they do is in
service of their country the hospital
has become home their work consuming
every minute of their day though global
news did witness a tiny reprieve
a little care for the caregiver with a
surprise visit from boutiva's husband
she hasn't seen him in months
crystal gomez and global news northern
harkeev region
what a powerful hug
a russian judge has convicted wnba
superstar brittany griner of possession
and drug smuggling
i made an honest mistake
and i hope
that
in your ruling that it doesn't end my
life here
despite apologizing and asking for
leniency the judge sentenced her to nine
years griner has already spent more than
five months in prison after less than a
gram of cannabis oil was found in her
luggage while she was trying to fly out
of russia her defense team says it is
going to file an appeal
we feel disappointment
you know when we saw britney
i think it was tuesday and we saw
and we talked to c on thursday and she
said see you on doomsday so looks like
she was right
it's hope griner sentencing could now
pave the way for a u.s russia prisoner
swap that would include her and an
imprisoned russian who was once a
prolific arms dealer
china is fired up coming up the
ballistic missiles it's launched near
taiwan
tensions keep rising in asia after u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
taiwan its president is condemning china
for conducting its largest ever military
drills around the small nation including
the launch of ballistic missiles the
chinese military though is calling the
operation a deterrent to collusion
between the u.s and taiwan which of
course beijing regards
as its own redmond shannon reports
china's biggest ever show of force in
the taiwan strait
footage from chinese state tv claims to
show the military exercises which taiwan
says included 11 ballistic missiles
fired into the sea the drills were
conducted in six areas surrounding
taiwan three of which overlapped the
island's territorial waters much closer
than during a similar flare-up in the
mid-90s beijing says the exercises are a
legitimate defense of what china regards
as its own territory
china's foreign ministry described nancy
pelosi's visit to the island this week
as manic calling the u.s house speaker's
presence a violation of the american one
china policy under which the u.s
operates a so-called strategic ambiguity
on taiwan's status and i want to
emphasize nothing has changed about our
position
and i hope very much that
beijing will not
manufacture a crisis or seek a pretext
to increase
its aggressive military activity
taiwan taiwan's president tsai inguine
called the drills an irresponsible
violation of the democratic island's
sovereignty she said she doesn't want an
escalation but that combat readiness has
been increased
it's likely the us would have factored
in the chinese reaction to pelosi's
visit betting that a full invasion of
taiwan remains unlikely even though
chinese president xi has never ruled out
such a move in autumn this year xi
jinping is going to most likely have his
third term approved
it means that they really
believe i suppose that they can't show
any sign of weakness japan also
condemned the operation claiming five
missiles landed into its waters the
drills are scheduled to run until sunday
redmond shannon global news
london day for alex jones ahead the
legal reckoning for one of america's
most notorious conspiracy theorists
some breaking news to tell you about a
u.s jury's decided right-wing conspiracy
theorist and infowars host alex jones
will have to pay the parents of a child
killed in the sandy hook massacre four
million dollars now this comes after
jones was found liable for defamation
earlier this year for repeatedly calling
the mass shooting a hoax and describing
the dead children and their grieving
parents as crisis actors as jackson
proskow reports the ruling could be just
the start of jones's legal problems
alex jones spent years peddling harmful
conspiracy theories the whole thing is a
giant house and profiting from them
telling his millions of followers that
the massacre of 20 elementary school
students never happened
sandy hook
is a synthetic completely fake with
actors for that he faced a defamation
suit brought by the parents of jesse
lewis a grade one student who died at
sandy hook elementary they say jones
made their lives and their loss a living
hell
my home was shot up
vehicles were shot up in my yard i don't
think that you understand the
repercussions
of
going on air with a huge audience and
lying
as the trial wore on jones kept up his
on-air attacks on the families even as
he finally relented in court it's 100
real i think sandy hook happened
and i think it's a terrible event the
stunning reversal came in a trial full
of surprises with accusations jones
withheld key evidence and lied under
oath that came to light after a mistake
by his own lawyers your attorneys messed
up and sent me an entire digital copy of
your entire cell phone with every text
message you've sent for the past two
years and that is how i know you lied to
me when you said you didn't have text
messages about saying
after the accidental release of data
jones asked for a mistrial but was
denied
now there's a rush to access the
contents of his phone
jones lawyer admits that includes
intimate text messages with roger stone
a close ally of former president donald
trump and a central figure in the
january sixth attack on the u.s capitol
it all suggests the sandy hook suit
could be the beginning of something
bigger as one of the loudest voices on
the american right risks being brought
down by his own words
jackson prosko global news washington
four louisville kentucky police officers
involved in the shooting death of
brianna taylor have now been charged
with several crimes including civil
rights violations the former officers
and police sergeant are facing charges
that include
lying to obtain a search warrant for
taylor's home
the u.s attorney general says federal
officials share but cannot fully imagine
the grief felt by her family
taylor a 26 year old black woman was
shot to death by officers during a
botched raid in march of 2020.
survival at sea how long did this boat's
62 year old sailor languish in frigid
waters
a french sailor was faced with a
life-threatening situation when his
racing boat capsized in the atlantic off
the coast of spain he spent 16 hours
trapped in his overturned boat before
search and rescue crews arrived at the
scene for what became a difficult and
dangerous rescue operation
ross lord has the harrowing details
accidents at sea often turn tragic but
this story is a breath of fresh air a
french sailor whose high-tech racing
sailboat capsized survived
the 62 year old sailor waited for 16
hours for the spanish coast guard to
rescue him in frigid water temperatures
estimated at 16 degrees celsius survival
experts say he'd likely have lost
consciousness and drowned if not for his
neoprene survival suit that added an
extra layer of crucial insulation and
this special sailboat designed to be
unsinkable and designed to float high on
the waves when overturned he was able to
stay dry from the knees up
water conducts heat away from your body
25 times as quickly as air does so once
you're immersed
the clock is ticking on monday night the
12-meter boat sent out a distress signal
off the galicia region of northern spain
after confirming signs of life coast
guard officials decided the sea was too
rough to attempt a rescue instead divers
waited until morning keeping the boat in
place by attaching five ton balloons an
operation they say verged on the
impossible he would have still felt the
motion of the vessel it's still a very
almost terrifying situation let's say
this boat get hit by a big wave or a
rogue wave
it if it went over on the side it could
have went down and the sailor might have
gone down with it for the rescue two
divers swam under the boat and freed the
sailor incredibly he had enough strength
remaining to start swimming to safety he
was airlifted to hospital finally free
from an ordeal that stretched on for
hours before its inspirational ending
ross lord global
news and that's global national for this
thursday night i'm farah nasser on
behalf of our whole global national team
i want to thank you so much for spending
part of your evening with us tonight's
your canada is cape bonavista lighthouse
in buena vista newfoundland and labrador
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]